بنك امريكي لغايه كم يوم فاتو كان بنك
كثير ناس حول العالم ما حتى عمرهم سمعوا
فيه لكن بين يوم وليله نمنا وصحينا لقينا
اشهر بنك في العالم
والاخبار عنه صراحه
فالسلطات الامريكيه قفلت البنك ووضعته تحت
وصايه المؤسسه الفيدراليه لتامين الودائع
يعني بالمختصر البنك اعلن افلاسه وبيعد
هذا الافلاس اكبر فشل مصرفي واول افلاس
لبنك امريكي من وقت الازمه الاقتصاديه في
2007 2008
البنك مختص في قطاع التكنولوجيا ومعظم
عملاء وشركات ناشئه ولمن زاد سعر الفائده
اعلن انه بيسعى لزياده راس المال بسرعه
لتامين سيوله كافيه قام عملاء البنك خافوا
كلهم يسحبوا فلوسهم والبنك ما عنده فاعلن
افلاسه ماذا يعني ابسط واسهل وصف نقدر
نقول لكم اياه
لحظه
على كل المنصات ما لها سيره الا افلاس بنك
السيليكون فالي ومعنا هذا الشيء وخطورته
وتاثيره على الاقتصاد في العالم وصراحه
كميه تفاصيل اقتصاديه معقده وفي نفس الوقت
وكمان غير مفهومه للناس اللي يعني ما لهم
في الاقتصاد فاحنا قلنا اننا بحاجه نتكلم
مع احد يبسط لنا الموضوع ويشرح لنا اولا
ليش موضوع افلاس البنك هذا خطير الى هذه
الدرجه وقالب الدنيا قدي كده وثانيا هل
فعليا مثل ما يقال انه يعني هذا بينذر
بازمه في العالم كله يعني هل المفروض
الناس تخاف ليه كل الدول جلسه تطلع كده
وبتطمن الناس على اقتصادهم لتبسيط الموضوع
وفهموا بشكل اكبر معنا من جده المحلل
المالي عبد الله مشاط اهلا فيك معنا عبد
الله يعني لما الواحد يشوف حجم الضجه اللي
صايره على البنك الان يصير يقول طب انا
عمري في حياتي ما سمعت فيه هذا البنك اصلا
ليش قد كده ما سمعنا فيه اذا هو قد كده
مهم معامل ازمه يعني
مساء الخير ساره ومساء الخير لجميع
المستمعين والمشاهدين وسعيدين مره اخرى
انه معاك رغم انه الموضوع الصراحه يساره
يزعل المستمعين وللاسف يعني كان حادثه
مؤسفه بس لازم تتعلم ونتكلم عنها
فللامانه بنك سيليكون فالي اتوقع الغالبيه
العظمى من الناس ما عمرهم سمعوا فيه رغم
انه يعتبر البنك رقم 16 في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من ناحيه حجم الاصول
وبس عشان اقرب الصوره للمستمع وللمستمعه
حجم اصول البنك يعادي الاجمالي اصول البنك
الراجحي في السعوديه فنحن فعليا بنتكلم
على بنك عملاق بكل ما تعنيه فليس بنك صغير
وله بنك اقليمي فاللي صار مع بنك سيليكون
فالي انه فعليا خلال يومين انفتحت ابواب
الجحيم والسهم هبط من مستويات عاليه جدا
268 دولار الى مستويات الواحد واربعين
شفنا تخوف هلع كبير بانيك الكل كان
يذهب الى البنك من اجل السحوبات وسحب
اموالهم تم سحب اجمالي 42 مليار دولار
خلال يومين بس عشان هذا الرقم للمجتمع
يسمعوا خلال الازمه العالميه في 2008 هذا
الرقم يعادل ثلاثه اضعاف الرقم اللي كان
موجود في 2008
اللي صار يعتبر كارثه من حيث اداره الازمه
فخلينا شويه نتكلم ساره انه ايش اللي صار
اليوم شرحنا بس مره بطريقه مبسطه عبد الله
اكيد اكيد
اللي صار خلال اليومين الماضيه بدات تظهر
اسماء معروفه ومحترمه جدا في سيليكون فالي
في اول ستريت يمكن ابرزهم في تمثيل مستثمر
معروف في بايبال مع ايلون ماسك وذكر انه
يجب على الشركات اللي هو استثمر فيها
ينصحهم انهم اسحبوا اموالهم من بنك
سيليكون فالي لانه البنك معرض لحاله من
الافلاس او الخطوره طبعا تصريح من شخصيه
معروفه مرموقه بهذا الشكل غالبا يعني سوف
يصل الى كل الناس الموجودين في السوق
فاللي صار بدا الضغط على السهم بدا تهون
وسارى شيء يسمى في عالم المال والاموال
اللي هو
باختصار عندما يذهب الغالبيه العظمى من
الناس للبنك من اجل المطالبه في اموالهم
وكلنا اموالنا موجوده بنوك والبنوك طبعا
لن تضعها جانبا يجب انه دائما تستثمرها
انها اموال اكثر ما عنده هذا الفلوس كلها
عشان يعطيها البنك صحيح صحيح
انه ياخذ الاموال من المودعين ويحاول قدر
الامكان انه يطلع عليه عائد من اجل ان
البنك نفسه يستفيد في كارثه بنك سيليكون
فالي اللي تسبب في هذا الهلع سواء من
تبثيل او من كل الموجودين في تويتر اليوم
انه البنكرتكب خطا جوهري قبل سنتين قرر
البنك انه جزء كبير من اموا تقريبا 40% 80
مليار دولار تساوي 300 مليار قرر انه
يضعها في في سندات تدعى
عائد واحد ونصف بالمئه هذا عائد كان يعتبر
ممتاز في وقت كانت الفائده فيه صفريه اللي
صار انه الفيدرالي رفع الفائده من مارس
والان الفائده فوق الاربعه ونص في المئه
ففعليا العائده اللي كان بيحصل عليه البنك
اصبح بلا قيمه واصبح البنك يحاول يستفيد
من اموال الناس اصبح العكس يعني كان في
خطا استراتيجي من البنك وبعدين صارت
الامور هذه كلها طيب الان هذه يعني احنا
حندخل في ازمه عالميه يعني يعني الناس ايش
لازم تعمل الان ايش لازم يخافوا
حاليا يوجد اكثر من اربعين الف حساب
اغلبها لمؤسسات اما ستار او شركات موجوده
بسيليكون
اودعت امواله في بنك سيليكون اللي هو باسم
سيليكون
البنك الفيدرالي الامريكي ما بعد 2008 قام
ببعض التشريعات اللي تحمي الى مبلغ 250
الف دولار هذه مؤمنه بنسبه 100% يوم
الاثنين اي شخص عنده 250 الف دولار سوف
يحصل عليها طب السؤال الاهم في حال مثلا
اودعت اكثر من 250 الف دولار ماذا سوف
يحصل لاموالي اي شخص سوف يعوض باول 250
الف دولار فوريا ومن ثم سوف يحصل على
وثيقه تثبت باقي ملكيه للاموال
هذا المبلغ لاحقا هذا بالنسبه للناس اللي
في الحساب اللي عندهم حسابات في البنك طيب
بس تاثير العامل لدرجه يعني البيت الابيض
جالس بيطلع بيقول لا الامور تمام يا جماعه
انه
وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ويعني في تطمينات
عالميه من دول يعني وبريطانيا برضو كمان
جلسه بتطمن
يعني بنتكلم تقريبا اول اثر اللي هو
المودعين اربعين الف شركه الان ليست لديك
قدره لا تدفع رواتب ولا عندهم القدره
يصلوا الى اموالهم يعني هذه اموال ليست
استثمار يساره موضوعه في حساب البنك
واختفى تماما وهذه مشكله كبيره لاربعين
الف شركه المشكله الثانيه اللي هي البنوك
اللي تتعاون مع سيليكون فالي بانك وبنوك
اصغر وعندها نفس النوع منها من المشاكل هل
هذا البانيك او الهلع سوف يمتد اليه ومره
ثانيه نشوف ممكن يتكرر لبنوك اصغر واصغر
لانه فعليا سيليكون فالي بانكي يعتبر بنك
محترم
فالخوف كل الخوف والان ليس من البنوك
الكبيره الخوف ان البنوك الصغيره في
امريكا انه فعليا هذا السنوبول او كره
الثلج تمتد اليهم هنا الخوف كله الصراحه
وهذه اكبر ازمه عالميه منذ 2009 بعد ما
شفنا
انهيار البنك اصلا
كان في عجل بيقولوا انه انهيار بنك يعني
سيليكون فالي بيهدد بازمه مصرفيه كارثيه
انه حتكون في عهد بايدن على العموم حنتابع
يعني القصه ونشوف
التداعيات زي ما قلت انت الموضوع فيه كثير
من العامل الهلع والخوف يعني بياثر فيها
على العموم نحن بنشكرك على هذه المداخله
كان معنا من جده المحلل مالي عبد الله
مشاط شكرا لك
[موسيقى]